[موسيقى]
هذه نشره المساء انا ريما مكتبي احييكم ما
نبدا بابرز العناوين
وزحفا بريا جديدا من اراضي في روسيا
عسكري
بوتين يعرضنا لست وثلاثين ساعه في العيد
واوكرانيا ترفض وتصفها بالفخ
[تصفيق]
اعدامات جديده في ايران واضرابته واسعه في
السجون دعما للاحتجاجات
اردوغان يرجح تقديم الانتخابات الرئاسي
[موسيقى]
انغام على الحدود بين بيلاروسيا واوكرانيا
وتكثيف للمناورات الجويه بين مسك وموسكو
ودعوات للذكور في بيلاروسيا لتسجيل
اسماءهم احتمالا للتعبئه
عسكريه قد تهبوا على هذه الجبهه في اي
لحظه فيما يتواصلوا تدفق السلاح الغربي
الى اوكرانيا مع عزمي كل من باريس واشنطن
تزويد اكياس للمره الاولى لمركبات خفيفه
مدرعه منها برادليه التي يعتمد عليها
الجيش الامريكي
الوضع على الحدود الاوكرانيه الروسيه وهذا
التقرير الحصري لمراسل العربيه حذيفه
هذا الجسر يفصل بين الدولتين اوكرانيا و
بلاروسيا دمرته القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
في الرابع والعشرين من فبراير مع بدايه
الاجتياح الكامل للاراضي الاوكرانيه والذي
لم يكن ليكون بتلك الفعاليه والقدره على
الوصول وحصار العاصمه كيف لو لم تفتح دوله
فيلاروسيا حدودها امام الجيش الاتحاد
الروسي
التي تبعد من هذه النقطه وانا اقف تماما
على الحدود حوالي ثلاثه ساعات في هذا
الاتجاه شخص نزل
دمر في الرابع والعشرين من فبراير العام
الماضي خلال اجتياحي الكامل للاراضي
الاوكرانيه جنود القوات المسلحه رصد تحرك
المعدات العسكريه القتاليه وكذلك
المروحيات التي عبرت الحدود والايقافهم عن
الزحف نحو عاصمتنا كيف تم اتخاذ القرار من
قبل حرس الحدود بتفجير الجسر في الوقت
الحالي ليس لديهم فرصه لتكرار ذلك
الاوكرانيون تعلموا الدرس فبعد ان
استطاعوا دفعوا لقوات الروسيه على
الانسحاب من حدودهم الشماليه عملوا على
تحصينها والدفع بحرس الحدود ومشاهده
القوات المسلحه والمدفعيه الى الحدود
وقاموا ببناء تحصينات ابتداء من كيف وحتى
هنا اخر نقطه للمراقبه مع الحدودي
البيلاروسيه
الحدود
والقوات المسلحه وتجري عمليات مراقبه على
مدار الساعه على الجانب البلاستي كذلك
نعمل على مراقبه الاجواء ومراقبه نهر
بدوريات في الوقت الحالي لا توجد اي خلق
في الحدود ونحن نضع بعين الاعتبار كافه
السيناريوهات وجاهزون لاي ظرف الا ان ذلك
لم يكن كافيه خاصه وان الاستخبارات
العسكريه الاوكرانيا تتوقع هجوما وزحفا
بريا جديدا من اراضي روسيا بعد ان دفع
الرسوم نحو 20 الف جندي عدا من كانوا
متواجدين بدايه الحرب في بلاروسيا حيث
قامت كيف ببناء جدار فاصل بين البلدين على
حدودها الشماليه وعززته بخنادقه وزرعه
الالغامه على الشريط الحدودي
الاجراءات التي قمنا بها في البدايه كانت
تدمير الجسور الرابطه بيننا سواء كانت
جسور النقل للسيارات او سكه الحديديه كما
قمنا بانشاء الدفاعات الهندسيه كالجدار
وموانع الدبابات وزرعنا الالغام على كامل
الحدود وحتى الطرق قمنا بتدميرها وكذلك
قطعنا الاشجار في الغابات بفتح مجال اكبر
للرؤيا كما عززنا من تواجد حرس الحدود
والقوات الخاصه والقوات المسلحه والقوات
الدفاع الاقليميه وغيرها من القوات
المنضويه تحت القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
والعسكريون يضعون عده سيناريوهات قد
يتبعها الجيش الروسي ابرزها الزحف مجددا
من اراضي بيلاروسيا نحو كيه وهذه الحدود
هي الاقرب اليها او محاوله الزحف للسيطره
على الولايات الغربيه مما يسمح بقطع طريق
الامدادات العسكريه من الغرب ما يجعلها
حدودا ذات اهميه استراتيجيه كبيره في هذه
الحرب لان القياده الاخرانيه تقول انها
واعيه للمخطط الروسي ومستعده لمواجهته لدي
فعادل لقناتي العربيه والحدث من الحدود
الاوكرانيه البلا الروسيه
بيلاروسيا تثير مخاوف الغرب بدعوات لتسجيل
الذكور لاسمائهم وصفه مؤشرات باستعداد مسك
للتعبئه لتعبئه العامه للقوات مجله يوزويك
الامريكيه ذكرت ان مقطع فيديو تم تداوله
على وسائل التواصل في بيلاروسيا يطيروا
دعوات لجميع المواطنين ذكور للحضور الى
مكتب التجنيد واوضحت المجله ان مقطع
الفيديو اثار ما خوف من حدوث تعبئه عسكريه
خاصه خاصه ان الاعلان ذكر انه على جميع
المواطنين الذكور بين الثمانيه عشر عاما
و60 عاما الحضور لمكتب التجنيد او اللجنه
التنفيذيه بالمدينه البيلاروسيه لتوضيح
بياناتهم
المقطع تم نشرح بواسطه الصحفيه
البيلاروسيه شهيره هنا ليو باكوفا التي
قالت نيوزبيك ان الاعلان يثير مخاوف الناس
بشده ويمكن تفسيره بانه استعداد محتمل
للتعبئه المستقبليه
[موسيقى]
ينظم
الاوكرانيه على الحدود مع بيلاروسيا حذيفه
عدل مراسل العربيه حذيفه امضيت يوما كاملا
على الحدود وظهرنا في نقل مباشر قبل هذا
كنت على اول نقطه الحدود ما هي ابرز
مشاهداته من الناحيه العسكريه اولا
تحياتي ريما في الحقيقه يعني اولا ااا هو
العمل العسكري والهندسي المستمر الذي
شاهدناه ونعلم انه بدا منذ حوالي اكثر من
شهر وحتى الان مستمر العمل على تعزيز
الدفاع في الحدود طبعا الكساندر بملوك هو
قائد
القوات المدافعه او قوات الدفاع عن كيف
اليوم ايضا صرح حول ذلك وقال ان خط دفاعك
يبدا من الحدود البلا الروسيه وقال ان على
حدود 1000 كلم نشرنا قواتنا وقمنا
بتعزيزات الهندسيه وهذا ما شاهدناها اليوم
عدد كبير جدا من الخنادق الجدار الفاصل
الذي ما زال همم عمليات الانشاء ما زالت
مستمره لاكمال هذا الجدار كذلك هنالك
جداول كبيره جدا تم حفرها واغرقت بالمياه
ايضا بالاضافه الى عمليات التنظيم
والالغام التي تزرع وكنا ايضا قد شاهدنا
هذه العمليات ليس فقط في المناطق القريبه
من الحدود ولكن من شيرليغ المتجهون الى ع
الحدود شاهدنا ذلك على الطرق وذلك الجسور
الصغيره في الوديان ايضا هذه الجذور يتم
اا تتم عمليه التلغيم والزرع المتفجرات
فيها وذلك طبعا هناك خطوط دفاع خط خلف خط
اذا ما استطاعت القوات ان تتقدم يكون
هنالك قد دفاع وخد دفاع اخر وهذا بالضبط
ما قاله اليكساندر لوكا اليوم حول خطوط
الدفاعات الكثيره والكثيفه حتى العاصمه
كيف قال ان هذه تعتبر من الحدود وحتى كيف
هذه خط الدفاع عن العاصمه كيف انت تجول
على الكره الحدوديه والمدن الحدوديه هل من
مخاوف وسط المواطنين من همم تصعيد الجبهه
او الجبهه الحدود مع بيلاروسيا
نعم يبدو ان هنالك يعني طمانينه بين
السكان خاصه انه الجنود الذين تحدثوا
اليهم والضباط الذين تحدثوا اليهم قالوا
ان لا يوجد سبب الان لاي مخاوف الان هنالك
احكام كبيره همم السيطره على الحدود هنالك
دوريات على مدار الساعه هنالك عدد كافي من
الجنود وهنالك دفاعات الهندسيه يبدو ان
ذلك انعكس عن المواطنين وجدتهم وطمانيين
تحدث اليهم قالوا اننا عشت ايام الحرب
الصعبه والان الوضع افضل بكثير اتحدث حتى
عن الخدمات التي كانت غير متوفره واصبحت
متوفره عندما اتينا الى هذه المدينه مع
بدايه الحرب لم تكن يعني كانت خاليه تماما
الان تشهد عوده كبيره جدا حتى القرعه
الحدوديه حتى الى اخر منطقه او منزل يعني
همم بالقرب من الحدود على بعد امتار قليله
وجدنا ان احد السكان يعيش الان في هذا
المنزل على بعد عده امطار فقط
الوضع اختلف تماما في الشمال الاوكراني
شكرا جزيلا لك انا معي من مدينه
الاوكرانيه على الحدود مع بيلاروسيا حذيفه
عادل مراسل العربيه
رفضت اوكرانيا عرض روسيا لهدنا في العيد
مشترطه سحابا روسيا من اراضيها وخلى
مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني ان العرض فخم
واصفا اياه بدعايه ياتي هذا بعد ما امر
الرئيس الروسي قواته بوقف اطلاق النار في
اوكرانيا لمده يوم ونصف اعتبارا من منتصف
نهار الغد السادس من يناير حتى بدايه يوم
الثامن من يناير
وبحسب بيان الكريم طالبت موسكو كياف بوقفه
اطلاق النار وسماح بحضور قداس عشيه عيد
الميلاد
[موسيقى]
السابعه لانتخاب رئيس مجلس النواب
الامريكي بعد فشل الجولات السابقه بسبب
خلافات داخل صفوف الجمهوريين وهي سابقه
تاريخيه ايضا
لم تشهد المجلس النواب هكذا انقسام
رئيس لمجلس النواب موضوع عقود
هناك محاوله
رئيس مجلس النواب يحتاج 218 صوتا ولكن
هناك نحو نائبا من الحزب الجمهوريه اعطاء
لما كرسي قبل التعهد بان يكون متشددا تجاه
الديمقراطيين والرئيس بيدن ويقوم بفتح
ملفات ضد الديمقراطيين
مقاسي
اذا هذه عمليات التصويت الجاريه الان ولا
يتوقع ان يرجع عنها رئيس على الارجح هذا
الموضوع سنبحث مع ضيفتنا من واشنطن بعد
قليل دكتور امل مدلل
الروسيه في اوكرانيا
باسلحه تفوق سرعتها سرعه الصوت من جانب
الاخر تحرك حلفاء كيف الغربيون نحو
امدادها بمركبات القتاليه لاول مره لكن
ليست ذبابات الثقيله التي طلبتها لمحاربه
روسيا حيث قال مسؤول في الالزي انها مكروه
عزمه فرنسا ارسال مركبات قتاليه مدرعه
خفيفه من طراز اي ام اكس
فيما قال الرئيس الامريكي في وقت لاحق انه
واشنطن تدرس رساله مركبات لاوكرانيا من
نوع برادلي القتاليه
بمدفع قوي والتي يعتمد عليها الجيش
الامريكي بشكل اساسي منذ ثمانيات لسهولتي
تحركاتها
[موسيقى]
اقتربت الحرفي اوكرانيا من اكمال عامها
الاول تطورات مختلفه عرفتها المواجهه في
الفقره او في الفتره الاخيره ابرزها دخول
اسلحه جديده الى ساحه المعركه من الجانبين
الاوكراني والروسي نتعرف على ابرز هذه
الاسلحه في سياق القصه التاليه
[موسيقى]
في اوكرانيا اسلحه مختلفه تدخل ساحه
القتال حلفائك الغربيون يتحركون في اتجاه
امدادها بمركبه قتاليه مدرعه لاول مره
فرنسا اعلنت عزمها ارسال مركبه قتاليه
مدرعه خفيفه من طراز اي ام اكس 10 ار
سيلكاف استراليا من جهتها قالت انها قدمت
لك اياه في 90 من مركبات التنقل المحميه
من طراز بوشماستر وهي وحدات مدرعه معززه
ضد الالغام ونيران الاسلحه الصغيره
وتهديده اخرى واشنطن هي الاخرى تدرس ارسال
مركبات براد للقتاليه الى اوكرانيا وهي
عربات مزوده بمدفع قوي من الوسائل
الاساسيه التي يستخدمها الجيش الامريكي
لنقل القوات في ساحه القتال منذ منتصف
الثمانينات مركبه من شانها ان تمنح
اوكرانيا مزيدا من القوه القتاليه وتعزز
قدرتها في حرب الخنادق اوكرانيا تستخدمه
ايضا صواريخ
الامريكيه الصنع تطلق من راجمات صواريخ
تقذف رشاقه صاروخيه وتحمل الراجمه 40
صاروخا من
عيار22 ميليمتر تطلق جميعها خلال 20 ثانيه
في المقابل امر الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين ادخال الفرقاطه الادمره القرش كوف
المزوده بصوارخ تسكن الى الخدمه العسكريه
لتتمتع بقدرات عسكريه كبيره وتعتبر من
اكثر الروسيه تطورا لديها خاصيه حمل
صواريخ مختلفه منها كاليبر وكين جالوت
سيركان وكروز يمكنها تنفيذ ضربات قويه
ودقيقه في البحار واليابسه صاروخ سيركونا
الاستراتيجي فرط الصوتي الذي يستطيع حمل
رؤوس مختلفه ومنها النوويه تفوق سرعته
سرعه الصوت قادر على ضرب اهداف على مسافه
تزيد عن 1000 كلم
تطورات تاتي في وقت تتوقع واشنطن استمرار
القتال الانيف لاشهر اخرى في جبهه القتال
الشرقي
بلال البشداني العربيه
[موسيقى]
في الاضراب عن الطعام لليوم الثالث على
التوالي فيما اعلن محمد مهدي كرمي
المتظاهر الايراني المحكوم عليه بالاعدام
عن دخوله في اضراب عن الطعام احتجاجا على
تاييد حكم اعدامه ومع زياده الدخول الضغوط
على المحتاجين السجناء في ايران بدات موجه
اضرابات عن الطعام واسعه في السجون وورد
التقرير تفيد بتعرض لصحه السجناء للخطر
وفق ما افادت ايران انترناشونال يجري ذلك
في ما تتحدث
عن اقاله قائد الشرطه الايرانيه العميد
حسن حسين اشتري بامر من المرشد الاعلى
الايرانيه
[موسيقى]
ولا حاجه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وتحت عنوان طلاب ايران يخاطرون بكل شيء
الا الانتفاضه ضد النظام من اجل الحريه
والتغيير كتبت صحيفه واشنطن بوسه
الامريكيه نقلا عنه شطاء ايرانينا قولهم
ان الثمن الذي يدفعه هذا الجيل من الطلبه
للمطالبه بحقوقهم اخذ في الارتفاع يوما
بعد يوم واصطى شهادات الايرانيين قابلتهم
الصحيفه متابع ما قلناه عن اقوال بعض
الطلاب والنشاطات
يتعرض الطلاب للقتل والاعتقال والمنع من
الحرم الجامعي ولهم احكام طويله بالسجن
[موسيقى]
النظام يزيد الضغط على الطلاب للحد الاقصى
بحيث ولا يمكنك المشي او ارتداء الملابس
او التحدث هو حتى الضحك بطريقه لا تتناسب
مع معايرهم نحن ندرك جيدا انه بمجرد توقف
الاحتجاجات سيعودون الى اقصى ضغط لهما مره
اخرى
تلقت نقابتنا تقارير عن قيام رجال الشرطه
بملابس مدنيه باختطاف طلاب في الحرم
الجامعي والضرب عشوائي من قبل قوات متطوعه
وتسبب وابل الغاز المسير للدموع والقنابل
الصوتيه وطلقات الرصاص على الطلاب
المتظاهرين في حدوث الكسور في الجمجمه
واصابات في العين
ووثقت وكاله حقوق الانسان الايرانيه
احتجاجات في 144 جامعه على الاقل واكدت
اللجنه التطوعيه لمتابعه اوضاع المعتقلين
اعتقال نحو 700 طالب جامعي حكم على 44
منهم بالسجن لعده سنوات في كثير من
الاحيان وقالت لجنه ان اكثر من نصف
المعتقلين ما زالوا خلف القضبان ويواجه
طالب واحد على الاقل تهاما قد تستحق عقوبه
الاعدام
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
صدام الينا
وفي اوروبا اهلا بك كيف اااه دخول الطلاب
معادله الاحتجاجات
وهناك نوع من رابط قوي بين الطلاب في
مختلف الجامعات كيف ذلك يؤثر على التحركات
في ايران الاحتجاجيه
اول اسمي نوبل
الطلاب الجامعات في ايران في الوقت الراهن
اييي
يشاركون في الاحتجاجات باعتبارهم شباب
والدور الذي يقومون به في الاحتجاجات في
الجامعات والثانويات هو دور كبير حتى الان
طالب من الثانويه
في ايران تم اعتقالهم اذا خلال هذه
الاحتياجات همم الاعتقالات تم في المدارس
او في الشوارع
بقائد الشرطه همم امر بذلك هل ممكن لذلك
ان يؤثر على سير الاحتجاجات يعني هل ممكن
للمحتاجين ان يواجهوه عنفا اكثر مع قائد
جديد اااه في هذا الموقع
حقوقيه اييه نغطي الاخبار المتعلقه اساسا
بكردستان ولا تتوفر لدينا معلومات بشان
الاوضاع السائده في طهران
المرجح هو ان القوات
النظام الايراني تستخدمه كل ما اتيح لها
من قوه لقمع المتظاهرين واحتمال الحصول
القمه اكبر واكثر اتساعا هو امر وارد
بخصوص
المساجين على الطعام ما هي المعلومات عنهم
وهل بامكان هؤلاء فعلا ان يقوموا
باحتجاجات لانه اصلا ظروفهم صعبه داخلها
السجن يعني انتم لديكم كثير من المعلومات
عن وضع السجون بحكم اعمالكم في مجال حقوق
الانسان
نعم هذا صحيح بالنسبه
لسجناء الاكراد اييه
لدينا امم
محمد
اضربت مهدي مدرسي وقد اضربت عن الطعام
بسبب تدهور حالتها الصحيه
وهي في الوقت الراهن تعاني كثير وكما
شاهدنا من خلال الحالات الاخرى فان اضراب
عني طعام من قبل السجناء الاساسيه
يؤدي الى تفاقم اوضاعهم وهذه طريقه
للاحتجاج على ظروف الاعتقال داخل السجون
الايراني
ضد الممارسات التي تعرضون لها على ايدي
النظام الايراني هذا طبعا ينطبق على كافه
السجناء سواء كانوا اكراضا او غيرهم
وهؤلاء سجناء لم تتاح لهم فرصه الحصول على
محامي للدفاع عن انفسهم امام المحاكم
الايرانيه محاكم الجمهوريه الاسلاميه داخل
ايران بطبيعه الحال هناك احتمال كبير بان
هؤلاء
الداخل ايران سوف
يواجهون ضغوط من قبل النظام الايراني وذلك
من اجل همم
الاعتراف
بامور لم يقترفوها بالضروره وهذا طبعا يتم
من خلال وسائل التعليم المختلفه فقد تم
اصدار حكم
ضد سجينين
كرديين وسد سجناء تم اتها هم بالمحاربه
انهم اعداء الله على الارض
[تصفيق]
في ازمه نواب الامريكيه المعتدلون
الجمهوريون يضغطون على مجموعه اقصى اليمين
الانتخابي
[موسيقى]
بسبع الجولات اقتراح فشل مجلس النواب
الامريكي في انتخاب رئيس المجلس وسخ
خلافات بين الجمهوريين فيما يسعى
المعتدلون الجمهوريون لاقناع المجموعه
المتشدده من جناح اليمين بترشيحه كفن
مكوتي يستغل هؤلاء نواب الغالبيه
الجمهوريه الضائله التي حققوها في
انتخابات منتصف الولايه في نوفمبر
لكي يفرضوا شروطهم ومن دون دعمهم لا يتمكن
مكارس من الوصول الى المنصب وقال نائب عن
تكساس ان الولايات المتحده تريد وجها
جديدا ورؤيه جديده وقياده جديده يشل هذا
الوضع ايضا مؤسسه مجلس النواب روماتها اذ
من دون رئيس لا يمكن للنواب ان يؤدوا
اليمين وبالتالي تمرير اي مشروع قانون ولا
يمكن للجمهوريين ايضا ان يفتحوا التحقيقات
الكثيره التي وعد بها ضد جوفا وقال النائب
الجمهوري
متاسفا لدينا عمل يتعين ان القيام به ولا
يمكننا متابعته
المذيع شون هاريتي في الفوكس نيوز احرج
النائب اليمنيه لورين بوبرد الذي رفضت دعم
مكارتي وادخلت عمليات تصويت لرئيس مجلس
النواب وهي وهي ومجموعتها في فوضى كبيره
ولم تجب على سؤال واحد والخمس دقائق
نتابعوا جزءا من المقابله
[موسيقى]
لك لكن
انا لست محبطه من الناس الذين ما زالوا
يصوتون معك بالمقاتل
من المتعه حيث تقتل الحزب الديمقراطي خلف
الترشي حكيم جعفرز لكن النائب لا يتمتع
بدعم بدعم عدد كافر من الاصوات لكي ينتخب
رئيسا لمجلس النواب قد تكون المواجهه
الحاصله سياسيا للجوبايدر اذا اكدت نيته
الترشح مره اخرى في عام 2024 وهو قرار قد
يعلنه مطلع السلام ومن المفارقات التي
شهدها اللقط حول مجلس النواب وانا زعيم
الجمهوري لمجلس الشيوخ مثل مكانه رافق
الرئيس الديمقراطي في زياره لكانتاكي
للاشاده ببناء جسر بتمويل من قانون البنيه
التحتيه الذي قدمه ونال اصوات بعض
الجمهوريين في الكونغرس
في السوق
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وقبل الانتقال لضيفتي من واشنطن دكتور امل
مدللي مستشاره في شؤون الدوليه نتابع انا
وامل والمشاهدين
الجوله الثامنه الانتخابي او محاوله
انتخاب رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي فشلت
الجوله السابعه منذ قليل
وروح مكانك لا رئيس لمجلس النواب الامريكي
هي سابقه منذ قرابه المئه عام كان شهد هذا
المجلس التاخير في انتخاب رئيس ولكن ليس
في التاريخ
الانشقاق والاختلاف وداخل الحزب الجمهوري
وليس بين الحزبين الرئيسين المتنافسين في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ابحث هذا الموضوع مع ضيفتي من واشنطن
دكتور امللي دكتور امل المشهد همم مشهد
البرلمان الامريكي يتخبط بهذا الشكل
لل- همم ناخذ الامريكي في الداخل وللمجتمع
الدولي ماذا يقول عن الاسس الديمقراطيه
التي تكون عليها الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
اهلا ديما شكرا كثير همم الواقع ان تطبير
همم الكاتب الذي كتب ديمقتها في امريكا هو
الذي قال ان الديمقراطيه هتغيان الاغلبيه
ولكن التي نراه اليوم في الكونغرس
الامريكي هو طغيان الاقليه فعلا هناك 20
نائبه من الحزب الجمهوري يمنعون حتى الان
انتخاب رئيس المجلس من حزبهم هم وهذا يشير
الى التمزق الذي يعيشه الحزب الجمهوري
اليوم الذي يفتقد الى القياده ويفتقد الى
همم العمل همم الوحده في العمل الجماعي مع
بعض همم الواقع ان في خلال هذه الدورات
اين ان هذه المجموعه وكانها مهتمه ب- اا
ايجاد الفراغ بالفضه اكثر من اهتمامها
حلول لان التقارير اليوم كلها تشير الى ان
كاظم
بعد التعديلات التي طرحوها وهذه التعديلات
اذا مررت ستؤثر كثيرا على الولايات كده
على الكونجرس وعلى الديمقيه في امريكا
فمثلا يقال التقرير تقول انه قبيله وهذا
كان شيء يعرضه في السابق كثيرا قبل ان
يطرح اين نائب في الكونغرس في مجلس النواب
يمكنه ان يطرح تعديلا او قانونا ل اا لعزل
رئيس المجلس
وهذا يعني ان هناك 435 فيتو الان سيصبح
اذا مر هذا في المجلس اي نائب يمكنه ان
يطرح عازل الرئيس وهذا يدعم رئيس المجلس
يدعم المؤسسه عطيه ايضا هذا خطير وهناك
ايضا اقتراح اخر يقال انه قبل ان يقدمه
لهم لكي يصوت له وهو منح اعضاء هي
المجموعه هذه همم منحها عدد مقاعد اكثر في
لجنه التي تضع قواعد عمل الكومنتريس وهذه
اللجنه هي اللي تقرا قوانين قبل الترحي
على المجلس بشكل عام فهي تستطيع ان توقف
اي اي قرار او اي قانون يتم طرحه على
المجلس بشكل عام وايضا اخر همم شيء همم
قيل انه قبل به وهو انه وضع يضع يضع حد
على عدد او دورات التي يمكن النائب ان
يكون ان يترشح فيها ويخدم في المجلس هذه
الامور كلها لا تضعف فقط الديمقراطيه
الامريكيه وتظاهر وان رئيس وانما ايضا
ستتحد من قدره مكارتي على الحصول على على
على اصوات اخرى لان الميتين همم عضو في
المجلس الذي يدعمونه
لا يقبلون منها التعديلات ويعتبرون
لك باع طويل في واشنطن همم تقيمين هناك
وتتابعين السياسه الامريكيه وخفاياها
برايك مشهد همم
الجمهوريين هذا لاي مدرسه يعني سيؤثر على
همم القاعده الشعبيه للحزب الجمهوري وهو
يتخبط منذ سنوات
هل هذا سيكون ااه دمج او له تاثير تخريبي
او ضرر كبير لصفوف الحزب
بشكل انت على حق لان الذي يحدث اليوم في
الكونغرس هو خطير لكن قلنا للولايات
المتحده للعمل الديمقراطيسي الولايات
المتحده ولكنه ايضا خطير بالنسبه للحزبان
الموجودين في الله في في
الحياه السياسيه
وخصوصا على حزب الجمهوري الذي يبدو حتى
الانطباع لدى جميع العالم جميع الناس ان
هذا الحزب لم يعد قادر على الحكم وهو حزب
عريق ولديه همم يعني همم جزاك كبيره في
الحياه السياسيه الامريكيه ولكن اليوم
كمجموعات متطرفه داخل هذا الحزب همم
اختطفت هذا الحزب يعني يقال الكثير ان
يقولون ان هذا الحزب الان مخطوط من قبل
هذه المجموعه فهذا سيؤثر تاثيرا على الحزب
وعلى كراسه على فرصه في المستقبل سؤال اذا
لم يتم سؤال اخير دكتوره امل ايه يحكي عن
الملفات التي سيفتحها الجمهوريون بحقل
ديمقراطيين يهم المشاهد العربي الملفات
ال- اا الدوليه همم ما التحقيقات التي
ممكن ان يساء البيضا غير موضوع افعل
افغانستان هل ممكن مثلا موضوع ايران ان
يعاد ويفتح
هي طبعا هناك الكثير من
الملفات التي خارجه من دون انهم يفتحونها
واحدى هذه الملفات هي ملف ايران وعلاقه
ايران بروسيا
وتزويدها بالسلاح وخصوص الدرونز هذا واحد
من الامور اعتقال الجمهوريون ان هذه واحده
من الامور الذين سوف يذبحونها خلال
التحقيقات وافغانستان
المواضيع الاخرى
فالتخوف ان هذه السنتين المقولاتين في
الكونغرس لن تكون سنتين همم يتم فيها
انجاز اي شيء وانما ستكون تحقيقات وستكون
هناك مشادات وتكون هناك همم ارقى سياسيه
وشلل الكونجرس الان مشلول حتى اليوم
الكلام يقول ان الذي يحدث ياثر على
السياسه على الامن القوم الامريكي لانها
مثلا لجنه اللجنه الاستخبارات لا تستطيع
الاستماع
هذا هذا هذا هو هذه الصوره اليوم في
واشنطن هناك قلق كبير على الذي يحدث شكرا
جزيلا لك دكتوره امل مدللي كانت معي من
واشنطن المستشاره في شؤون الدوليه شكرا
اذا المشاهد مباشره
للمجلس النواب الامريكي في محاوله سابعه
همم لانتخابي او جوله الثامنه محاوله
ثامنه لانتخاب مجلس رئيس مجلس النواب
فشلت سبع محاولات في اليومين الماضيين
تقريبا انه معدل جلستين او ثلاثه في اليوم
اا يعقدها المشرعون الامريكيون في محاوله
للاتيان برئيس مجلس النواب همم كما سمعنا
من ضيفتي من واشنطن هذا يعطل الحياه
السياسيه في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
همم لانه لا يمكن البث او تشريع قبل
الاتيان برئيس مجلس النواب
[موسيقى]
استقبل مئات الفلسطينيين بقريه عارات كريم
يونس اقدم اسير سياسي في العالم والذي
يعانق الحريه بعد ان امضى 40 عاما في
السجون الاسرائيليه
هكذا بدل احتفال بالاسير المحرر كريم يونس
هنا في بلدته عاره بعد ان قضى اربعين سنه
في السجون الاسرائيليه قبل اشهر فقط فقد
والدته وبدا وكان العالم قد تغير تماما
بنظره وقد يحتاج وقتا للتالم
من بلد لا تشبه البلد
لكن احنا بنعتبر انه يعني وجودنا بالسجن
هو محطه نظليه وانتقلنا من مرحله الى
مرحله رغم محاوله اسرائيل من على الفرحه
بتحريره وتركه في شوارع مدينه يهوديه فجرا
الا ان اعدادا كبيره من الفلسطينيين وصلوا
الى هنا للمشاركه في فرحه تحريره من بينهم
زملاء سابقون له في الزنزانه واقارب لم
يرونه من قبل
شعور جدا صعب لما اول نظره له اول ما
قبضته وشفته همم طريقتنا عارف عن حالي انا
من الاردن واول مره بزور فلسطين وصادف هذا
الحدث انه بخروج كريم يونس وجئت على قريه
ازور هذا الحدث
كتب كريم في رساله اهداها لشعبه بعد خروجه
قائلا ها انا قد عدت متقلا ب 40 سنه من
الاسر بقليل من الشعر الاشيب ولكنني عدت
بعد ان تحول الى ايقونه فلسطينيه وكان
عميد الاسرى الفلسطينيين لم تكتفي الحكومه
اليمنيه الجديده ب 40 عاما من السجن
وسارعت الى التلويح بسحب جنسيته كريم يونس
وابعاده الى قطاع غزه
من قريتي عاره العربيه
وقت تتابعونا في نشره المساء
في اليابان السمكه الاغلى في العالم تباعه
بسعر خيالي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في وقت عقدت فيه
المعارضه التركيه اجتماعا لتنسيق جهود
للانتخابات القادمه اكد رئيس تركيا رجب
طيب اردوغان في خطاب امام اعضاء حزبه انا
موعده للانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه
المرتقبه يمكن تقديمه بينما تبقى هويه
مرشح المعارضه لمنافسه اردوغان حبيسه
اجتماعات المعارضه
[موسيقى]
خطوات قليله فقط امام بدء الاستحقاق
الانتخابي في تركيا بشكل رسمي الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان اكد ان حسبه يدرس
امكانيه تقديم موعد الانتخابات دون الذهاب
الى انتخابات مبكرا على حد قوله
م افضل من يعرف اهميه الانتخابات 2003
التي ربما نجريها في وقت مبكر قليلا بعد
مراعاه الظروف الموسميه تصريحات اردوغان
طلقتها المعارضه اثناء اجتماع ما بات يعرف
بالطاوله السداسيه وهو تحالف سته احزاب
معارضه يحاول تنسيق الجهود للفوز
بالانتخابات القادمه لكن خلافات حول
اختيار مرشح مشترك يمثل المعارضه في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله باتت تقلق
الشارع المعارض لا سيما ان اكبر حزبين في
الطاوله السداسيه بعيدان كل البعد عن
التوافق على هويه
المرشحا انا كمال
خصوصا بعد القرار القضائي بحق اكرم اوغلو
الذي استبعد من المنافسه ميرال اكشن زعيمه
حزب الخير ترى ان فرص رئيس بلديه اسطنبول
اكرم امام بلو في الفوز بالانتخابات اكبر
من حدودك ملك الجدار اوغلو زعيم حزب الشعب
الجمهوري المثقل بعداء شريحه من المحافظين
بسبب مواقفه السابقه من قضايا عديده كانت
تمسهم بشكل اساسي خلال العقدين
الترشح للرئاسه لكن الاكثر حظا وكمال
اوغلو رئيس حزب الشعب الجمهوري الذي اسس
هذه الطاوله وضمن استمرارها حتى اليوم لكن
ميرال اكتشنر لا تريده مرشحا لرئاسه
الجمهوريه المعارضه التركيه تعاهدت في حال
وصولها الى السلطه باعاده العمل في النظام
البرلماني مع تقييد كبير لصلاحيات رئيس
الجمه والغاء النظام الرئاسي المعمول به
حاليا ومنح استقلاليه للقضاء وعدم تقييد
الحريات العامه المرشح المشترك للمعارضه
لا يبدو انه هويته ستظهر خلال المدى
المنظور في حاله الشرخ في الطاوله
السداسيه وان حاول الزعماء واخفائها لكنها
كواليس غير بعيده عن العدسات ولا شك ان
توافق زعماء المعارضه على مرشح وحيد هو
اهم استحقاق لهم خلال الانتخابات المرتقبه
زيدان زينجو العربيه اسطنبول
ينضم الينا من اسطنبول الصحفي ورئيس تحرير
انزكان تركيا اهلا بك هل المعارضه جاهزه
للانتخابات قبل موعدها
عندما نتحدث عن الانتخابات فنحن نتحدث عن
جو الانتخابي ربما منذ اكثر من عام
وبالتالي يمكننا الحديث
مبدايا ان المعارضه جاهزه لاي انتخابات
وبالفعل هي قالت اكثر من مره ودعت اكثر من
مره الانتخابات مبكرا في السابق لكن عمل
اجرائي وكما جاء في التقرير هناك الكثير
من الاشكاليات التي
تعصف بالمعارضه في اطار سواء وجود مرشح
توافق للرئاسه وهي نقطه مهمه اساسيه الامر
الاخر نحن نتحدث عن انتخابات بقانون
انتخاب جديد في حال تمت الانتخابات بعد
الشهر همم خمسه من العام من هذا العام وهو
من المتوقع ان يكون التاريخ المتوقع
للانتخابات يوم 14/05 تحديدا حسب الكثير
من التسريبات الاعلاميه وبالتالي نحن
نتحدث عن قانون انتخابي جديد فيما يتعلق
بالانتخابات القادمه وخاصه فيما يتعلق في
البرلمان وهذا يعني ان المعارضه يجب ان
تجمع اوراقها وتذهب بقائمه مشتركه اذا ما
ارادت الاغلبيه البرلمانيه الكاسحه على
حساب حزب العداله والتنميه والا فا
البرلمان والرئاسه سيخسرونها
اذا كان الانتخابات في شهر خمسه او سته
معه 90 يوم قبل هذا يعني عليه ان يعلن بين
الان وشهر فبراير اواخر فبراير او همم
مارس كحد اقصى همم لماذا اردوغان يريد
تبكير موعد الانتخابات
خلف هذا القرار
هناك نقطتين رئيسيتين في هذا التاريخ
النقطه الاولى اذا استكملنا ان الدوره
الرئاسيه الكامله للسيد اردوغان ربما
سندخل في جدل دستوري لان الدستور ينص ان
الرئاسه لدورتين يعني للرئيس دورتين فقط
وكلنا نعلم ان السيد اردوغان قد اكمل
الدورتين فعليا لكن هناك جدل قانوني
ودستوري في امكانيه ترشح السيد اردوغان
وبالتالي عندما نتحدث عن انتخابات نسبيا
مبكرا فربما يحسم هذا الجدل الدستوري
والقانوني هذا اعتقد السبب الرئيسي الامر
الاخر من المتوقع ان تشهد البلاد خلال
الايام القريبه القادمه النوع من انواع
التحسن الاقتصادي وبالتالي اعتقد ان السيد
اردوغان يحتاج ايضا الى هذا الجو الاي في
في الضلع الانتخابات التي يعقد يعني الذهب
اليها لكن اذا ما انتظرنا الى شهر همم الى
الشهر السابع الموعد المقرر الانتخابات في
وضعه الطبيعي فربما ستسوق الامور في الفعل
اقتصاديا اكثر من ما هو في الواقع الان
وبالتالي ربما التحسينات
والوعود التي قام بقطعها قبيل الفتره همم
بالامس وقبل الامس في اطار زياده الرواتب
وغيرها مثل هذه الفرحه لم تعم او لم تكتمل
في شهر سبعه ربما يقطف يعني ثمارها في شهر
خمسه او منتصف شهر 5
[موسيقى]
اخترت مجله
البريطانيه المتخصصه في مجال السفر وسياحه
اختارت مدينه العلا شمال غرب السعوديه ضمن
عجائب الدنيا السبع لعام 2023
واشاره المجله الى ان العلا اصبحت ذات
شهره عالميه نظرا لما تختزله من تاريخ
وارث واثار لم يكشف النقاب عن معظمها حتى
اليوم وتضم العلماء تاريخيه انسانيه يظهر
من بينها موقع الحجر الذي بنته ابداعات
الحضاره النبطيه وسجل الموقع بوصفه اول
موقع تراث عالمي ضمن لائحه منظمه يونسكو
في السعوديه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تشهد بريطانيا المزيد من الاضطرابات في
حركه النقل مع اضراب السائقين قطارات
ويؤثر الاضراب الذي تنفذه نقابه سائق
القطارات عزف على عملي 15 شركه مشغله لسكك
الحديد غالبيتها في انجلترا لكن عددا
قليلا منها يوفروا خدمات نحو اسكتلنداوي
في الاسنان تعهدت الحكومه البريطانيه
بانهاء الاضطرابات والاضرابات وطالبت
النقبات
[موسيقى]
اضرابه سائق القطارات اربكت ترتيبات سفر
الناس في بريطانيا فول عنا من توقف خط
رحلته اكثر من مره مطره الى تغيير مسار
رحلته التي امتدت لسعد ليجد نفسه اخيرا
عالقا من دون وسيله نقل بديله للوصول الى
وجهته النهائيه
الى مانشستر لزياره عائليه استغرقت ثمان
ساعات على متنقتارين ومحاولته وصول الى
بيت توقفت في يورك اما رحله قطار من هناك
الى لندن جيده ولكن الان لا توجد قطارات
للذهاب الى مطار لوتون علي ان ابحث الان
عن حافله او سياره
لبعض سائق القطارات لا خيار لديهم كما
يقولون سوى الاضراب عن العمل لاعاده مدير
شركاتهم لمطالبتهم بزياده اجرهم وتحسين
الظروف عملهم
70 كم باينينز لا نريد ان ينزعج الناس
ولكن للاسف موقف الحكومه المتعنت يزيد من
ايرباك الناس وانزعاجهم على المستوى
الشخصي يفقد سائق قوى القطارات الماله
عندما يضربون عن العمل
نقابه اذلف التي تمثل سته 96% من سائق
القطارات في المملكه المتحده ارغمت 15
شركه تدير رحلات القطار على تعليق خدماتها
في اضراب قد لا يكون الاخيره مع غياب اي
مؤشر لحل نزاع المغربي لا اضراب جديدا
جدولا لسائق القطارات لكننا نقبتهم
ستجتمعوا لمناقشه الخطوه المقبله لاشعار
اداره شبكه البنيه التحتيه للسكك الحديديه
بايام اضرابات اخرى قبل اسبوعين على الاقل
من موعدها مصطفى زاروه العربيه من محطه
حضر خبراء الصحافي الولايات المتحده من
انتشار المتحور الجديد من اوميكرون
المعروف باسم اكس بي بي 1.5
وامكانيه انتشاره بسرعه في بقيه الولايات
الامريكيه حيث تمثل السلاله الجديده من
المتحول نحو
41% من حالات كورونا المؤكده في امريكا
تحذير خبراء الصحفي امريكا رافقه تحذير
اخر هذه المره من بريطانيا اكدوا فيها ان
المملكه ليست مستعده لمواجهه موجه جديده
من المتحورات كورونا في ظل انتشار المتحور
اكس بي بي 1 5 شديد العدوى في البلاد
المتحول اكس بي بي 1.5 تم اكتشافه في
اكتوبر عام 2022
[موسيقى]
والولايات المتحده
من الممكن ان يكون بوابه متحولا اخر اكثر
خطوره مع زياده عدد الاصابات
الف دولار في مازالتوكيو التقليدي لمناسبه
اي ما يخرج من ضعفي سعر السمكه الاغلى
ثمنا العام الماضي لتكسره بذلك المنح
التراجع السائد على صعيد الطلب منذ بدء
الجائحه وهذا الرقم ادنى بكثير من السعر
القياسي المسجل عام 2019 لكنه يعكس
انتعاشا للمزاد الرمزي بعد ثلاث سنوات من
انخفاض الاسعار
واجهه مسؤولون في ولايتكاليفورنيا
الامريكيه بالاسراع في عمليات الاجلاء في
منطقه ساحليه شديده الخطوره مع قدوم عاصفه
شديده وهطول امطار تسببت في قطعه تيار
الكهربائي عن اكثر من 76000 شخص
بمنطقتي خليجي سان فرانسيسكو ونحو 19000
اخرين على طول الساحل الاوسط كما الغت
سلطاته عشرات الرحلات الجويه وقررت اغلاق
المدارس في احدى الضواحي بالاضافه الى
تحرير سكان شمال كاليفورنيا بالابتعاد عن
الطرق
قبل الختام هذه نظره اخيره على في نشره
المساء على جلسه مجلس النواب الامريكي
الذي يحاول في جول جلسه ثامنه ان ياتي او
ينتخب رئيس لمجلس النواب بعد سبع مرات
وسبع محاولات
وهذا ما جاء في نشاط المساء
العسكريه جديده
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اعدامات جديده في ايران واضرابات واسعه في
السجون دعما للاحتجاجات
[تصفيق]
اردوغان يرجح تقديم الانتخابات الرئاسيه
واحزاب المعارضه تعجزوا على الاتفاق على
اسم مرشحها
وانتهت نشره المساء دائما شكرا للمتابعه
انا القاكم عن قريب باذن الله والان
العربيه 360 مع زميل طاهر بركي مساء الخير
يعني ما هو جديد من معلومات عن جلسات مجلس
النواب الامريكي الذي لا يزال بانتخاب
رئيس تقديم الانتخابات التركيه شبح الحرب
كما قلت قبل قليل على الحدود الاوكرانيه
البيلاروسيا وكيف ضرب الامير وليام الامير
هاري كما يقول الاخير الاخير على الاقل في
كتابه الجديد كوني معا